i got a small confession to make both to
yourself into the audience i've been
holding on to this story since we got to
speak so i had uh carl benjamin sagan of
a card on the show
a few months ago and it was slap bang
as chas was happening so we're talking
peak race tensions
right and i've spoken to carl before
we get on really well episodes are great
but for some reason i had this ambient
anxiety throughout the day
leading up to it and i started talking
to him and i was really nervous i don't
usually get
nervous especially when speaking to
guests for a second time so it's just a
friend
how are you how's this that and the
other sure and um
i found myself being super super i felt
like i was training on eggshells as i'm
talking to him
and then upon listening back even some
of the things that i said i didn't agree
with i didn't agree with myself
and what sort of things so yeah sorry
for for instance
um we were talking about should the
faulty towers episode be taken down
what's happening with little britain
variety released a list of 10
problematic movies which need
warnings under discussion before and
after watching and i
put this stuff forward to carl and he
gave his thoughts
and i just after that was done i said i
pushed the rhetoric of my compassion too
far i was saying basically
i don't think that anyone should be
offended which isn't true because
in order to communicate you have to risk
being offensive that's the way it works
another jordan petersonism
so anyway what i found was that i had
somehow managed to and that
listeners may be able to sense this
within their own lives
i'd become so ignorant to where the goal
posts were
that i wasn't i didn't even know what
sport i was playing anymore
and i feel like this is the end goal
which
a lot of the um smarter people
who are using uh
just justice movements to further a
particular
agenda are hoping to achieve to move the
goal post
so fast that you don't know what's right
what's wrong well it's anything else
and i was super nervous and that yeah
yeah yeah yeah you're completely
personally you're completely right and
he here are a couple examples of that
um tony abbott former australian prime
minister
uh was appointed by the uk government as
a trade advisor
the last week in the days leading up to
his appointment
various people led by a number of
left-wing broadcasters and newspapers
claimed that tony abbott is a you can do
it homophobe misogynist
granny killer uh they did actually do
that weird
and uh global warming denier that's
that's the big four isn't it bingo
well no the big the biggest one the
fifth one they actually weren't quite
brave enough to do which was to accuse
him of racism
but they accused him of all the other
stuff and uh he's none of those things
by the way he's none of those things
he's a terrific terrific guy and a
terrific public servant and the former
prime minister of australia for goodness
sake
um so anyway but the point is is that
the day
the day before the appointment the day
of the appointment and the day after it
the guardian had on the front page both
days
the government appoints misogynist
advisor
okay as if that's proven okay it's
proven i mean they put it in quote scare
quotes just to
make sure they were legally a bit on
better terrain but that was what they
said
now if i was a young woman or a young
man
growing up with an ordinary level of in
curiosity
i would look at that or might look at
that and think
that's awful and that's awful the
british government's deliberately
appointing someone who
who hates women now
as it happens the the longer you go on
in life the more you
you you get a sense of things the more
you rise what's [ __ ] in the guardian
and what's the real
life but it is easy to see how somebody
can be
given a wrong view of an entire society
once you imbibe little things like that
now that's an easy one let me give you a
harder one
the killing of george floyd
um we are in a very powerless position
on this
all of us because i don't know how much
time you've spent in the us
i spend a bit of okay so like me
they have racial problems that we don't
have here i would submit
every country has racial problems
there's a peculiar and particular one
that has existed in america throughout
history
you could also argue that in the most
militarized country in the world
the most militarized law enforcement it
has a
likelihood of fatal encounters with the
public
that is higher than say in britain
where most of the time the police just
spend the time running away from
protesters
um and
but the point is is that if you didn't
know america that well i'm giving here
the the
the nicest best analysis of something
that's going on at the moment that i can
do
if you didn't know america very well you
didn't know very many americans and you
read
that this white cop had been allowed
to kill a black man on camera for eight
minutes
and that was okay as it were
and this happened a lot
you would join black lives matter
absolutely you would want to join
something that said that's not on that's
not right
and the problem is there are these
moments by the way black lives matter
was just primed for a
george floyd-like event and um
and lots of reasons to do with lockdown
i think the sort of the world was in a
way
but what i think happens in those
moments is
it's very hard for people to get a
correct sense of exactly what is going
on so
maybe the police in america do kill
black people
with impunity is a thought that crosses
your mind
maybe america is a racist state maybe
the british police are like that maybe
britain's like that maybe we're all
racist maybe there's such a thing as
white supremacy and it's everywhere and
so on and on and it all starts from that
first
inaccurate estimation of what's going on
so the killer of george floyd is in
custody
awaiting trial on charge of murder
he literally has no defenders in the
public sphere
he yeah the lawyer but nobody says i
think he did great
so what is this utilization of this one
appalling incident and it's widening out
not just to encompass say all police in
the minnesota area
or all police in that state all police
in america
every white person every white person on
the planet no
no you don't get to do that no way
but in that moment you see certain
very very bad actors advancing
because they feel they've got an
advantage and that is the moment when
people become
worried because it's hard to interpret
exactly what the
situation is and bad actors
deliberately pump lies into the system
they say yes you can do this in america
because black lives aren't worth
anything
that we they were there was a very
moving press conference with some of the
police in new york
the police she was just standing with
his colleagues saying
people are getting away with saying
things like
uh one activist said i don't even know
if we don't know if we're black if our
children will return from school or
whether they'll just be shot by the
police and this policeman was saying
that isn't the case in an environmental
yeah it's not the case but again if you
don't know the country very well or if
you do and you have a certain
understanding of it or a
misunderstanding of it or
if you're a long way away it's possible
to imbibe those ideas
and so that's why i say that one of the
deranging things in our time
is that a very significant number of
people particularly young people
have been given or have given themselves
an erroneous interpretation of the
society they're in
and that's how you end up with the
lunatic you know writing
a book about the in defense of looting
and that's how you end up with people on
the streets of portland running around
looking for nazis and not being able to
find them and so smashing in some old
woman's face
now that's that's how you get there and
reasonable people of any political
direction just have to be able to say no
we're not going along you know you
what it is actually it's like the roman
legion thing that the people in portland
sort of tried to do
they use terrible and
very freakish events to push
forward and behind them is a whole
legion of hell
that is the purpose that is what blm and
others have been doing
and it has to be said by people of every
background that is not on you should not
be able to make defamatory
claims sweeping claims about whole races
of people and whole societies
in this manner and at the moment
certainly in the weeks immediately after
that it was very very difficult to say
that
it's becoming easier but i wish it's a
classic example of
i wish we weren't stopped from having
that discussion and we're only stopped
from having it
because dishonest actors say if you add
any nuance to
to it then you are basically on the side
of the guy
who killed george floyd
you